- Voici les nommés dans
la catégorie premier rôle
masculin comédie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ces présentations sont
maintenant chose du passé.
Hommes, femmes et personnes
non-binaires seront désormais
regroupés dans une même
catégorie, qui passera
de cinq à huit finalistes.
- Et le gagnant est...
MARA GOURD-MERCADO, DG, Académie
canadienne cinéma et télé.
- Ça fait très longtemps que
et l'industrie et les membres
demandent à ce qu'il y ait
moins de catégories pour
rajouter de la valeur prprprix.
- Mais la nouvelle mouture
soulève des questions en matière
de parité homme-femme.
SOPHIE PRÉGENT,
présidente, Unios s s artistes
- Si on constate, dans cinq ans,
que 80 % des trophés ont été
remis, ou des nominations, ont
été remis à des hommes... plus
ou moins ri,i,i, là. C'est ça
qu'il faut éviter, en fait.
- L'organisation des Gémeaux
n'a pas prévu de mécanisme à cet
effet, mais promet de s'aj
en fonction du prochain gala.
MICHEL COULOMBE,
chroniqueur cinéma- D'abord, ile
que cette décision des Gémeaux
n'est pas complètement
indépendante.
(chanson en anglais)
- Parce que l'Académie
canadienne du cinéma et de la
télévision, la grande soeur
de la section québécoise,
avait déjà adopté les prix
non genrés pour le Gala
des Écrans canadiens.
- C'est aussi une décision
d'affaires : comment redonner
du tonus à cette cérémonie-là,
sachant que l'ensemble
des cérémonies de remise
de prix un peu partout
perdent de l'audience?
(applaudissements)
- L'ADISQ préfère maintenir
la catégorie "interprète
féminine", estimant que...
- - - - - Notre reine, Gisèle L!
- Les trophées non genrés
ouvrent néanmois la porte à une
plus grande diversenenenenenres.
- Il n'y aura plus de limites,
et c'est ça qui est vraiment
le fun, c'est l'ouverture
à la diversité.
- Mis à part les catégories
masculine et féminine,
les Gémeaux abolissent
une cinquantaine de prix, qui
sont jugés trop similaires.
L'Académie va donc distribuer
88 statuettes au lieu des 139
habituelles pour un gala
de plus courte durée